تفاعل واسع لقته صور حي الكدوه في مكه
المكرمه بعد الانتهاء من اعمال ازاله
العشوائيات تظهر الصور الحي قبل وبعد
اعمال الازاله والتطوير التي تقع في
المنطقه المركزيه وجاء تنفيذه مشروع
التطوير عشوائيات حي القدوه بعد استكمال
ما يخص اجراءات تثمين العقارات والتعويض
والحرص على توفير البدائل السكنيه
المناسبه للسكان الحاليين في المنطقه
المستهدفه واعطائهم الاولويه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل عربي
هانز بيان حياك الله
كيف ترى الصوره الان في حي الكدوه
بعد ازاله العشوائي
نعم خالد اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه طبعا صوره مختلفه تماما عما كانت
عليه
الكدوه تحديدا او حي الكدوه سواء من خلال
العقارات الموجوده المنازل ايضا اشكالها
طريقه البناء كانت تبنى في هذه المنطقه
طبعا نتحدث عن سته الاف عقار كانت مبنيه
على هذه المنطقه بشكل غير منظم وغير مرتب
ايضا كانت هذه البنى او البنايات او ايضا
العقارات مبنيه على اسس غير ثابته من
ناحيه البناء التحتيه من صرف صحي من كذلك
مياه من ايضا التمديدات للكهرباء بسبب ان
هذه العقارات هي بنيت بشكل منظم من افراد
استخدموا هذا الحي كباقي الخمسه احياء
الاخرى التي يتم
من قبل هيئه تطوير مكه المكرمه لتطوير
العشوائيات سواء في حي الكدوه او كذلك
الاحياء الاربعه الاخرى طبعا قبل ما ابدا
عن هذا الحي ونتحدث عن هذا الحيه لو نتخيل
الصوره التي كانت مبنيه في هذه المنطقه
الجبليه او العقارات التي كانت مبنيه في
هذه المنطقه الجبليه كانت بشكل بنايات على
شكل اشبه بالمدرجات طبعا تم
تطويرها بشكل كامل ايضا تم استكمال ما يخص
اجراءات التثمين العقارات وتعويض لاصحابها
كذلك توفير البدائل السكنيه المناسبه
للسكان الذين كانوا يقطنون في هذه المنطقه
طبعا عمليه التطوير جاءت خالد وكذلك
مشاهدي قناه العربيه بسبب اعاده تكوين
البيئه العمرانيه في هذه المناطق
العشوائيه سواء في حي القدوه او كذلك
المناطق الاخرى بسبب ايضا نشاه هذه
العقارات في مخططات وكذلك تقسيم اراضي
سابقه بدون اعتماد او بدون او تكون او
كانت عقارات غير مرخصه واستخدام هذه او
استخدام الافراد لها وبنائها بشكل عشوائي
في هذه المنطقه طبعا نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه
تحديدا الذي التي نشاهد صورها مساحتها
تتجاوز المليون متر مربع طبعا هناك كما
ذكرت الكدوه واحده من خمس احياء اخرى هي
تقوم هيئه تطوير او الهيئه الملكيه في
منطقه مكه المكرمه بتطويرها وهي بجانبها
طبعا حي الكدوه تحديدا لعله يكون هو
الموقع الاستراتيجي كونه قريب من الحرم
المكي وكذلك قريب من برج الساعه وكذلك
موقع الاستراتيجي من ناحيه ايضا انه محاط
بالط الرئيسيه والطرق الدائريه التي سوف
تساعد ايضا الحكومه السعوديه مستقبلا في
عمليه ايضا تنفيذ خطوطها من اجل المعتمرين
وكذلك في الحجاج في موسم الحج في بنايات
وفنادق او كذلك تطويرها كمساحه لكي تكون
مهيئه وجيده
للموسم الحج وكذلك العمره شكرا جزيلا لك
من مكه المكرمه من حي القدوه مراسل
العربيه نصفيه